[Music]
[Applause]
the Detroit Lions are Going to the NFC
title game second time in franchise
history Lis Brown Lions radio color
analyst and uh member of the Lions
alltime team he joins us on the program
who would have thought that we would
ever come to this day lus as long as
I've known you that we'd be talking
about the lions in the NFC title game
how emotional has this been for you as a
former
player oh my goodness Dan it it's just
been everything it it what it does is it
just brings back memories and you start
thinking about the guys that you play
with and the guys that never got the
opportunity you know to just reach this
point and you just look what happened to
the Lions over those 30 some odd years
and just just every bad thing that can
happen did happen to this organization
this franchise and it just look so
refreshing to see now that they're on
the top and still climbing still
climbing but we got a nice young team
here okay more emotional the first
playoff win or what happened this
weekend ah for me I think it was the
first playoff win because again it had
been 30 some OD years not since the 91
team or 92 team um that they were we
were able to win that and for me being
in that game you know playing with Barry
Sanders and the Kevin Glovers and the
Jerry balls the great players that I
played with just to be in that game and
like I say a lot of those guys came back
for the game it just brought us back to
the Silverdome days which is now
Amazon uh I was watching jir Gibbs and
his ability to make people Miss in the
Box I mean that's very Sanders likee and
I I I don't throw that compliment out
very often I mean Gibbs is a
special special running
back yeah you could see some things and
you're right so do I man every time I
say Barry name and say it with another
players I go wash my mouth out with soap
because you're right you can't do that
but man jir I seen some things that make
me say okay he has a little something of
what the little big fella has and stuff
you know so it makes me reminisce about
Barry but you know there'll only be one
Barry but the way we use jir Gibbs not
only in the Run game but the passing
game all we want to do is get that young
man out in space and let him do what he
do D all right give me the game plan for
the Lions going to San
Francisco yeah hey rely on our Big
Fellas up front I'm telling you not not
just because I was a big fella hey the
old line has been playing awesome all
year long that's what this team is
relied on if Jared needed protection the
old line is there to give it to him when
jir and David Montgomery need a hold the
run through the old line is there to
provide it for those guys that's who we
leaned our team on this year that's who
Dan Campbell has his faith in to lead
this team and they've been doing a
wonderful job so we gonna have to
control the line of scrimmage period for
us to win up there well congrats Lis
you're not done yet good luck out in San
Francisco and and maybe we'll see you at
the Super Bowl that sounds great my good
man thank you lus that's lus brown he's
the analyst for the Lions on radio he
was the sixth overall pick back 1985 he
won a Super Bowl with the Buccaneers and
uh a member of the Detroit Lions alltime
team it was nice to see some of those
players including Barry Sanders Calvin
Johnson celebrated and celebrating with
the Detroit Lions because if there is an
America's team a true a true America's
team it's it's Detroit